最近人気を集めたくて日本に来て生配信を
したり動画を作ったりしている外国人が
多いですこういうクリエイターのために
日本でやっておきたいことリストを作って
みました日本の伝統的なゲームバトル
ロイヤルに参加すること初外国人優勝を
目指して桜島のカルデラで生配信すること
whatup
GU清水の舞台から飛び降りることやって
みて噂の呪いのビデオテを友達と一緒に
見ること全員で見てねゴジラのすかに
潜り込むこと俺がいい女を紹介するから
彼女とのデートを生配信してね名前えっと
山崎麻美横須賀の米軍基地内を撮影する
こといや許可なくても入れると思うよだ
からやってみて走ってくる新幹線とどっち
が先に避けるかゲームをすること
犬村に宿泊することパだ気分転換に
ドライブをすることクラウンたちが走っ
てる時にフグを釣ってそのまま食べること
そうだ新鮮じゃないとanyoneEL
Get
buy忍者にドッキリしてみる
こと暇があれば池袋の西口公園でブラブラ
すること2月に富士山に登ることいや登山
器具はいらない再生数が大事なら宿泊先の
4階に止まることそう日本では4は幸運の
数字ではっと半蔵に喧嘩を売ってみること
絶対に面白い生配信になるからいや渋谷も
原宿もいいけどやっぱ人がもも密集してる
ところでいたずらをしたいのであれば軍艦
島に行ってすること静内さんと腕相撲を
すること大丈夫だ僕が支度をしますので
大きな梅干を一口で食べることそうこう
すると日本人は関心します
YouTuberボクシングをすること
日本には高村守るっていう小さなyouバ
が今試合相手を探してるから彼に
チャレンジしてみて眠っている天狗の花を
掴んでみること桐かから布を盗み取ること
まさんに自分の名前を伝えることいや言っ
とくけどそんなに日本を使って再生数を
稼ぎたいならば自分の国で日本の伝統的な
文化であるハキリに挑戦する
こと
JA